[Musik]
wer sucht der findet sie Sinnbilder zur
Lage der Nation
Sri Lanka ist ein Land im
Ausnahmezustand von der Pleite bedroht
der Politik betrogen ein Land also das
Schmerzen erduldet
die Menschen bringen Opfer nicht nur
wenn es ihr Glauben verlangt wie bei
dieser hinduistischen tempelgemeinde es
trifft jeden ins Sri Lanka viele hart
manche härter
diese Zeremonie der Qualen erklärt mir
der Mann solle die Götter besänftigen
milde stimmen dahinter steckt dann also
doch was alle ins Sri Lanka teilen
die Hoffnung auf bessere Zeiten
Schlangen stehen schon wieder wenn sie
ihn ist kostbar dieser Tage denn Sri
Lanka bekommt Treibstoff nur gegen
Devisen harte Dollars wieder stark noch
Bürger haben sie teilen ist das Gebot
der Stunde es gibt für alle etwas für
alle etwas zu wenig ein QR-Code wird
gescannt damit keiner zu viel zapfen
kann der Mangel hat sich etabliert die
Rationierung ist organisiert die Technik
soll unbestechlich sein anders als der
Mensch
sie geben uns nur fünf Liter pro Woche
das ist für unser Geschäft als
freewheeler-fahrer ein riesiges Problem
damit kommst du nicht deine ganze Woche
zu Recht so kann die Regierung einfach
nicht weitermachen es ist alles brenzlig
angespannt wir verdienen nicht genug die
Wirtschaftskrise trifft uns heftig
mit etwas spritem Tank kommt magode
Gedichte über die Runden Fahrgäste zu
finden ist ohnehin schwierig jeder muss
sein Geld zusammenhalten weil jede Rupie
zählt gehen viele lieber zu Fuß
Magdeburg kann das nachvollziehen ihm
geht es ja nicht anders jeder Einkauf
ist eine Rechenaufgabe reicht das Geld
oder reicht es nicht
das hat jetzt fast dreimal so viel
gekostet wie vor der Krise das sind
verrückte Preise wie sollen die Leute
das Bezahlen von dem was ich in der Tüte
habe muss eine Familie eine ganze Woche
leben aber das reicht doch nicht wenn du
kleine Kinder zu Hause hast wie bezahlst
du dann die Milch oder den Tee oder die
Medikamente
die Frage die sich magode getäglich
stellt ist die meist gestellte Frage ins
Sri Lanka wovon soll ich morgen leben
wovon meine Familie ernähren
dieser Mangel hat die massenmobilisiert
Zehntausende demonstrierten gegen
Korruption Missmanagement krumme
Geschäfte die Liste der politischen
Versäumnisse ist lang aber die
Verursacher der Krise haben von der
Krise selbst wenig gespürt als das Volk
die Paläste eroberte staunte es über
Luxus entdeckte eine Welt von der es
selbst nur träumen konnte
wir haben nichts zu essen und diese
Bonzen lebten im Luxus ist doch klar
dass uns das aufgeregt hat also dachten
wir lasst uns mal den Sportraum
ausprobieren den Pool das war ja alles
von unserem Geld bezahlt ich habe auf
dem Präsidentenstuhl gesessen heute
schäme ich mich dafür ich will nicht auf
demselben Stuhl sitzen wie diese Leute
die Sri Lanka in den Ruin geführt haben
24 Jahre alt war also mittendrin seiner
Mutter war schnell klar dass das
gefährlich werden könnte
ich habe ihm gleich gesagt mach da nicht
mit er ist trotzdem gegangen er hat
nicht auf mich gehört aber er hat ja
nichts Falsches getan das ganze Land hat
doch protestiert nicht nur er
doch das System schlug schnell zurück
hart und brutal die alte Regierung war
weg aber die darauf folgten kamen auch
aus den Reihen das ist tabletsmans und
wenn sie davon sprachen ist müsse wieder
Ordnung herrschen dann war das eher die
alte Ordnung im neuen Gewalt die
Anführer der Protestbewegung wurden
festgenommen viele gefoltert auch wie
Mucki saß im Knast wurde verprügelt er
steht jetzt unter terroranlage muss mit
langen Gefängnisstrafen rechnen
was haben sie mit unserem Land gemacht
bin ich kriminell oder sie sie treten
unsere Rechte mit Füßen und wenn wir
protestieren werfen Sie uns ins
Gefängnis
an Zukunft kann wie Mucki nicht denken
er fürchtet den Prozess das Urteil
überleben sei das einzige Ziel das er
hat
Sri Lanka ist ein Paradies mit
Bilderbuchlandschaften die Touristen aus
aller Welt auf die Insel locken
das Land wird seine Menschen bräuchten
die Einnahmen gerade mehr denn je aber
es kommen nur noch sehr wenige Ausländer
im Zeichen der vielen Krisen
sucht man ein Symbol für den Niedergang
landet man schnell beim Tee weltberühmt
hoch geschätzt war Tee aus Sri Lanka
immer ein Exportschlager die Industrie
machte viel Geld die einfachen Pflücker
machten zwar viel weniger aber sie
konnten ihre Familien ernähren woran
kann von Kindesbeinen an auf den
Plantagen geschuftet er spürts in seinem
Fingern im Rücken am ganzen Körper
früher war das Geschäft in Ordnung aber
jetzt wird Pflücker verdienen kaum Geld
und die teefabriken auch nicht wir
machen weiter jeden Tag irgendetwas
müssen wir ja tun aber im Grunde ist es
sinnlos wenn wir keinen Dünger keine
Pestizide bekommen dann gibt es für uns
keine Zukunft die ganze Industrie
kollabiert
sie kollabiert weil die Ernten mau sind
die Ernten sind Mauerfall Dünger und
Pestizide fehlen die fehlen weil sie
ohne Devisen nicht importiert werden
können höchstens gegen Preise die kein
Pharma mehr bezahlen kann der Staat hat
in seiner Geldnot die Subventionen
gestrichen
es geht bergab immer nur bergab 50%
weniger Ernte beim Tee das heißt für
pflücke wie hoch eine karage es geht
jeden Tag ums Überleben
woran eine karage denkt viel darüber
nach wie es so weit kommen konnte er ist
frustriert
Bauer war immer ein respektabler Beruf
ein Sprichwort sagt wenn der Bauer sich
die Erde von seinen Händen wäscht dann
ist er ein König aber heute ist der
Bauer kein König er ist ein armer Hund
da haben uns die großen Politiker
hingebracht das ist ihre Schuld dieses
Land war ein stolzes Land das auf
niemanden angewiesen war nach der
Kolonialzeit standen wir auf eigenen
Füßen aber wir haben alles vergessen was
wir mal gelernt hatten jetzt sind wir
ganz unten
woran erkennt sich ein mundgerechtes
Kissen aus betelnussblättern Gewürzen
das Kauen darauf gibt ihm einen leichten
Rausch eine Betäubung die seine Wut
lindert woran eine karrage fühlt sich
verkauft im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
und nicht zu unrecht
ausländische Kredite die meisten aus
China haben solche Mega-Projekte
finanziert Flughäfen wo keine Flugzeuge
starten oder landen
Kongresszentren die keiner braucht
Autobahnen auf denen keiner fährt eine
bizarre Liste von Investitionen allesamt
in den Sand gesetzt und produktiv und
kreditfinanziert das fliegt Sri Lanka um
die Ohren
Geltungssucht Korruption Misswirtschaft
fast immer steckte der Clan der Roger
paxas dahinter eine Politiker Dynastie
die Sri Lanka über Jahrzehnte im Griff
hatte inzwischen sind Sie politisch
abserviert doch ihre Hinterlassenschaft
drückt schwer
wenn Doktor ja singe zur Arbeit knattert
bekommt er das zu spüren dreimal die
Woche ist hier Sprechstunde was der
Doktor benötigt bringt er mit in den
Bergens Sri Lankas ist der Arzt nicht
immer um die Ecke wer ein Krankenhaus
braucht muss in die Stadt dennoch für
ein armes Land konnte sich Sri Lankas
Gesundheitssystem sehen lassen aber die
Krise hinterlässt jetzt auch hier ihre
Spuren für Hilfe braucht muss Hilfe
bekommen des Doktors Grundsatz stößt an
seine Grenzen
die Gesundheitsversorgung ist kostenlos
für die medizinischen Leistungen die wir
hier anbieten müssen die Patienten
nichts bezahlen keinem Pfennig das
Problem ist allerdings dass wir nicht
immer alle Medikamente vorrätig haben
wir können sie verschreiben aber die
Patienten müssen dann versuchen sich die
Sachen irgendwo anders zu schaffen
hat sich die Situation also in letzter
Zeit verschlechtert
ja früher war das besser wir hatten
Medizin und konnten uns auch noch um die
Ernährung der Leute kümmern aber wegen
der Wirtschaftskrise mangelt an allem
auch an lebenswichtigem
zeig mal deine Zunge man kann deutlich
erkennen dass die Zunge entzündet ist
das ist ein Zeichen für Eisenmangel in
der Ernährung es fehlt dann gesunden
Lebensmitteln das ist der zentrale Punkt
warum die Menschen hier krank werden
kranke Menschen ein krankes System es
ist die Last die das ganze Land spürt
überall von den Bergen bis zur Küste
Negombo ist ein malerischer Ort unweiter
Hauptstadt bei Touristen beliebt für
frischen Fisch berühmt das alles galt in
besseren Tagen die Segelboote im Hafen
das mutet romantisch an und ist doch oft
aus der Not geboren ohne diese laufen
die Motoren nicht der Treibstoff ist
meist nicht aufzutreiben oder nicht zu
bezahlen
Anthony Fernandes hat schon viele seiner
alten Weggefährten aufgeben sehen er ist
75 fährt seit mehr als 50 Jahren raus
früher hatten wir nur Segelboote aber
früher gab es auch mehr Fisch heute
musst du Meilen weiter rausfahren sonst
fängst du nichts mit Segelbooten kommst
du nicht weit das dauert zu lange diese
traditionelle Fischerei gibt es nicht
mehr wir brauchen Motoren die brauchen
Diesel sonst kommen wir nicht dahin wo
die Fische sind
die Fischer von Negombo haben keine
großen Ansprüche hatten sie noch nie sie
wollen arbeiten um davon leben zu können
der Stress die Sorgen die sie und so
viele andere ins Sri Lanka Teilen auf
den ersten Blick ist das oft gar nicht
zu sehen Anthony sagt wir lachen nach
außen aber tief im Inneren weinen wir
Fischer zu sein ist ein hartes Los es
macht dich kaputt andere fahren morgens
ins Büro Sitzen am Schreibtisch fahren
abends wieder heim mit einem festen Lohn
in der Tasche da ist alles sicher bei
uns ist das anders wir Fischer können
nur auf Gott vertrauen Sri Lanka ist ins
Feuer gefallen und es ist schwer da
wieder rauszufinden irgendwie machen wir
weiter aber wenn die Krise anhält dann
schaffen wir es nicht mehr
ob morgen genug im Netz ist die
Unsicherheit der Fischer lässt sich wohl
aufs ganze Land übertragen Sri Lanka ist
eine Insel voller Sorgen das Paradies
kämpft mit den Sünden der Vergangenheit
und es kämpft um seine Zukunft